ladylee Arosa pretty really deal all the
material losses of the model the days
when the Cossacks defended czars
frontiers with their swords and steeds
are long gone but at the cadet training
school in the southern Russian city of
Stavropol the Cossacks are undergoing a
revival the military is once again a
popular employer in Russia now parents
can send their children here to be
trained in the Cossack tradition but
there's more to it than just skill with
a whip and a saber cuz I got them a
Cossack is a Russian Orthodox warrior
cuz I cossack has an important man who
wears his Cossack hat with honor and
defends his homeland the Stavropol
training center has two classes next
year a third will join them Vadim
Stadnyk AUB's family have been Cossacks
for generations
he's now sent his own son to be trained
at the cadet school
what my money of the poor the most
important thing is that we really can
love for the motherland the boneless
couple that we were prepared to ward off
every enemy every attack it's a very
unsettling situation in the Caucasus not
far from here do you miss Georgia
Michael Kaiser that's also why stand a
cop says he's lending a hand to the
local police the Cossack auxiliary force
has the blessing of the Kremlin and
local leaders they fear an influx of
Muslim terrorists from the troubled
Caucasus region the Russian Orthodox
Cossacks are supposed to help ward off
this threat
the Cossacks are also expected to lend
respect and moral authority to local
officials who are often mired in
corruption and scandal but so far the
joint patrols have not apprehended any
terrorists boy just put in a little
short cut off we come across all sorts
of crimes our officers find drugs and
illegal weapons called again there's
vandalism brawling sometimes a theft or
two the conflict with the local Muslim
population goes back many generations a
few hours to the west near the Kuban
River it's still very much in evidence
under the Czar's this was where the
Russian Empire expanded into the
Caucasus the Cossacks a fierce band of
horsemen helped secure the frontier
often against resistance from the
region's Muslim inhabitants why you
could overpower ancestors conquer this
region with their blood every meter of
soil here is drenched with the blood of
Cossacks but the boy left off back then
the borders of the Russian Empire
extended along rivers that's why areas
like this one are so important to us
right then we should buy a cup of
washing the Union but historically
speaking the Cossacks who are honoring
their ancestors here are not actually a
distinct ethnic group in the 15th
century the Cossacks were mainly runaway
serfs who banded together as free
warriors Bosco was talking about Julius
Co nd I will talk about this for
generations The Fearless bands of
horsemen lived free then in the 18th
century the czars incorporated them into
the Imperial Army the break with the
state came only with the Soviets who saw
the proud and independent Cossacks as a
threat to communism nowadays the state
counts about a million registered
Cossacks not all come from a Cossack
family of long standing to be a Cossack
all you have to do is share their values
and be a member of the Russian Orthodox
Church
at home Dimitri Belikov
does keep some livestock but he doesn't
have any horses he says they're too
expensive and a Cossack no longer needs
horses to ride out in defense of the
motherland
Agron apart Kamil so how are you good
Northy this is our land this is my farm
my house my honor my government I had
the mood boom with the mic and I'll
protect it and help keep order and if
need be I would go to war for it was my
budget to need I booked on your saying I
went back in Stavropol Vadim's Donna
Cobb says his work with the official
Guard unit is going well he and his
comrades are helping the police on
patrol but their main client right now
is the Russian Orthodox Church which
like the Kremlin wants to use the
cossacks for its own purposes STAAD nick
off and his men carry out regular
inspections in the churches looking for
explosives but the real reason is a show
of strength as Donna Cobb admits so in
Ocean Moga signal storable we have all
sorts of sects nowadays in Stavropol
illegal organizations that say their
religious groups but have nothing to do
with any actual religion total new you
look in your small and then we've got
the Islamic fundamentalists the
terrorists there's no telling what they
might do even organized terror attacks
Oakville Kira
here in southern Russia the Cossacks are
no longer just colorful figures from
history just as it did back during the
days of the czars Russia once again has
its band of free warriors just now
without the horse and saber